Wonderful.
Okay, great.
David Arfin, thank you so much
for being on my show
20 Minute Leaders.
My pleasure. Good to be here.
I can't wait for this.
[--]
Yeah.
Well, first off, where are you
because this is not a virtual background.
A lot of people have this
is as a virtual background,
but you're actually there.
I am right now staying in
Potomac, Maryland,
which is a suburb of DC.
I was actually born in Potomac, Maryland.
So, it's quite a funny coincidence.
No kidding.
Yes.
So, we are very close
to Great Falls Park,
which is just, it's a national treasure,
as are all of our national parks.
Wonderful. Thank you so much for taking
the time to do this.
I think it's very, it makes a lot of sense
that this is your background,
given that you're an expert
in renewable energy and working in
fast growing companies that are making
a real difference in the world.
Very quick background.
Stanford MBA
in the Graduate School of Business.
Moving on, you held
numerous executive positions,
Solar City, Ninedot, so many others
that I missed along the way.
But I'd love to hear a little bit
about you from your journey
going into the space.
So, I'd say the journey,
I can't say, gee,
when I was a business school student
or an undergraduate,
this is what I always
wanted to do in my life.
Each thing is a response to the needs,
opportunities and creativity
that I can bring to it.
So, I started professional life
as a community organizer
in the Jewish community in Los Angeles.
Working for the GCRC,
which brought in some values
that I care deeply about.
I worked in Washington, DC
as a health staffer
and as an education lobbyist.
Then I went to business school,
got a entrepreneurial bug.
Started a few companies,
and then ended up
in 2006 seeing the Al Gore movie
Inconvenient Truth.
And that was eye opening both from
the issues around climate change,
as well as the business opportunities
to create some interesting,
sustainable businesses.
So, by a little work
and a bunch of discussions
and happenstance,
I came up with a pretty good idea,
together with some other people,
to do a solar leasing program.
So, instead of somebody having to make
a massive investment
on having to buy something
that they never bought before,
and they think it's a good idea,
but it's a hard decision to make.
Instead, change the ownership model,
work with some of the incentives
that are out there
and create something new.
And I did that.
And I have been fortunate
to be able to take that idea.
And once that spun off of it
and spend the last 14 years
working in energy with fantastic people.
Unbelievable.
And, you know, one of the things
that have always intrigued me
as an entrepreneur,
I'm thinking about solar
and I'm thinking about this transition of
how do you get,
even when the technology matures,
how do you get people to buy
into this, the average citizen?
And I think a lot of it ties back
to the way people manage their money
and how they think about
expenses and rewards,
because essentially the sell,
if I understand it correctly,
let's say solar panels on the roof.
The sell is you're gonna
pay a lot of money now,
you're gonna return the money slowly.
And within a few years,
they're gonna reach a break even point,
and then you're going to start saving money.
But it's a very different thing than,
you're not saying,
"Here, I'm gonna give you cash."
You're saying, "You're gonna lose less."
Right? It's a different mindset.
It's a different sell.
Yeah.
A lot of what I think about
is risk and reward.
Right.
And kind of behavioral economics.
So, if you basically take,
we all have these little things here, right?
Yup. These are new cell phones.
And we know we are going to be subscribing
to expensive services
the rest of our lives.
And if somebody came up to us and said,
"Gee, wouldn't it be nice
if you just put up $30 thousand
and we will,
that's gonna prepay the rest
of your life of cell phones."
You may say, "That's a terrific idea."
But instead, I'd rather spend a thousand
dollars a year on it
over the next 40 years, hopefully.
Right.
Maybe 50 if I'm pushing it.
But whatever that took with it,
whatever that create it.
So, the telecom industry
built out the infrastructure
and made a compelling proposition
to customers to pay by the month,
to pay by the day.
To pay, in autos, it's paid by the mile.
And that's basically how you get
new technologies adopted faster.
You know, the old Xerox machine,
it's hard to sell it for
five thousand dollars to an office.
Sell it for 10 cents a copy?
Go ahead. All day long.
Right. Okay. That's fascinating.
But so, nevertheless,
you watch the Al Gore movie.
Is that really the turning point for you
when you realize that
there was a huge problem in the world
and then you decide to spend
the next 14 years
working on these things?
Well, I kind of knew
there was a problem in the world.
I just didn't know how I connected to it.
Okay. So since then,
you've held all these positions.
When did you join
Solar City as Vice President?
I joined Solar City
in the very early days
in May of 2007.
Wow.
And so, I had the idea
of a solar leasing product.
Lyndon Wright and Peter Wright,
the co-founders of Solar City,
instantly got like financing was important
and perhaps just as important
that Elon Musk understood
that customer financing was important.
So, they basically said,
"Ah. That's the idea that we need
to be able to go
from being a small company
to being a large company
to being a massive company."
Ended up getting 35% market share
in the United States.
Which is just unheard of.
Unbelievable.
So, essentially as part of Solar City,
talk to me a little bit about this journey,
because  you have the privilege of
being as a pioneer in this realm
of transitioning a country and going solar
and seeing this technology develop
and seeing how customers interact with it.
So, and you're actually working
on strategy, right?
Within solar cities.
So, how do you work on strategy
in the context of renewable energy?
Wow.
Well, you start by understanding
what the customers want
and where where markets are.
In energy.
you have to be very policy sensitive
because everything depends
on the tariffs that you pay.
The incentives and the penalties
that are out there.
A few two different things.
So, you have to understand
and it's a very interdisciplinary area,
which is why I like it.
So, some of my time I get to be,
what is strategy?
It's a combination of economics,
of consumer behavior,
risk and psychology,
finance, energy, hardware,
devices and accounting
and policy.
And I'm not an expert
at any one of those things,
but I have enough experience
and kind of just see
or observe things in the world
where you can combine those.
And if you do that, you can come up
with some interesting solutions.
And what I loved about Solar City was
they let me create this solution,
encouraged me to create it,
put their muscle behind it
and changed the organization,
changed the industry.
And that was a commitment from leadership.
And Lyndon Rive in particular,
to understand that we needed
to sell things differently,
we needed to approach
the consumer differently.
And it was a really interesting
disciplinary approach
and it was a big risk.
I thought it was
obvious that it would work.
And there were months
and months that was hard to do.
And in particular,
when we started this,
remember I said we joined in 2000
and I joined Solar City right
as they head-started in 2007.
That was right before
the big crash of 2008.
So, to go to the Wall Street banks
and to say,
"We'd like you to buy a portfolio
of 5000 rooftop solar systems."
during the midst of a housing crisis
that we have never seen before.
And the security on this is gonna be
a little less than you would get
on a second mortgage.
You know, we had a lot of doors slammed
in our face.
But we had good people
on our team
and very good people
on the Morgan Stanley team at the time.
And we were able to get deals done.
And that set a trajectory for me,
for the business and for the industry.
Unbelievable.
And through Solar City,
did you ever cross parcels so with Elon
and get to hear a little bit
about his perspective
and how he sees the industry?
I did.
And Elon is a very bright guy.
Much more introverted than
his public persona on Twitter.
His Twitter, I was just about to say, yeah,
He's really an engineer.
Right.
And he sees what is possible
and then doesn't understand
why you go from what is possible to,
why can't you do it tomorrow?
Let's get this thing out there.
Let's push.
Because he started a PayPal.
He actually had a natural,
let's just say, dislike
or suspicion of banks.
Yeah.
He said basically,
you're gonna go to banks.
You're gonna explain this idea.
You're gonna explain to them
how they can make a lot of money
and they're not gonna know
what to do with this
or they're gonna try to steal your idea.
Right.
So, he's an incredibly bright guy.
And he was very supportive of
helping to steer the ship towards
a mass customer experience.
He just wants everything
done really quickly.
Perfectly.
Yeah.
And yesterday.
And as a result, the management style,
he gets a lot out of people.
And everybody who's worked
in an organization for him
for a period of time will tell you that
they contributed.
If they didn't contribute, they were out.
And they gave a lot of themselves.
And that's, I called it a management bonus
or a management characteristic.
You work really hard.
I mean, I think at the end
a lot of people are working on ventures,
and I'm thinking constantly about things
that I wanna do later on,
as an entrepreneur myself.
That's part of the motivation
for speaking to you here
and getting this inspiration.
At the end, when you're talking
about changing the world
and actually changing the world,
not writing that on a slide deck
and saying, "I'm gonna revolutionize XYZ."
But actually going and doing it.
You know, I think that at the end
you can forgive a little bit
of an offset in expenses myself,
but you can forgive a little bit
of hard work and a little bit of pushing
and the results are showing.
But, David I'm talking to you now
as a young entrepreneur.
I'm gonna go on my own path.
I'm gonna have to make some
difficult decisions on what I work on,
how I work on it and with who.
And I'd love to get a little bit of insight
into this world of renewable energy,
which you're an expert on by now.
What are some of the things
that are happening around the world
in this industry
that I should be aware of?
Because honestly,
it's not the sexiest thing
in the hallways of Stanford right now
and probably not in the lot of places
in the world.
So, let's talk about renewable energy.
Right. So, there's so many different ways
to start to answer that question.
Good. We have to we have about
seven minutes
so, we can talk about everything.
So we'll flow on advice
that's not a problem.
So, I am against of just separate
to the grid connected world
where we can improve our energy sources,
and the off grid world.
And there are, call it,
two billion people out there
in the world today
without reliable access to electricity.
Two billion without electricity.
Without reliable access.
Without reliable access to electricity.
So, and some without electricity at all.
But it's also the reliability.
If you have electricity
three or four hours a day,
that's a lot better than nothing.
But you still have have other needs.
So, I would start with the ability
to look at the world.
That is what we call off-grid
or semi off-grid and look at what it is
that can be done to bring electricity
and literally light to those people.
And that's maybe
250 million people in India
throughout Latin America and Africa.
And there's just, suburbs are
going to be very different.
They don't have all the appliances
because they don't have electricity,
obviously.
So, bringing in a light, having them also
on a pay as you go system,
I think is really terrific and important.
And whether that's the
lights for their house
or there in the village.
Whether it's a light
for their working place,
whether it's refrigeration,
being able to charge their cell phones.
Let me ask you this, David,
Is the problem,
so, we have electricity in many places
around the world.
And we have these systems.
Is the problem,
I want to know whether it's
the chicken or the egg problem?
Do we have the technology
and we just have to spend money
to scale it and implement it there?
Or are we looking for more
financially viable solutions,
more technologically savvy solutions
to make it more efficient?
And because we don't have them yet.
That's why we don't have electricity.
Which one is it?
So, for solar, for wind, for bio gas,
we have the technology today.
That is plenty good to be able to make us
much, much more energy independent.
We still have to evolve.
We still have to improve.
We still have to make inverters better.
We have to capture more hours
of sunlight in different ways,
Per square foot that you're using.
But the technology is there.
I think a second part of energy
is storing it.
So, you can have windmills tilt.
Wind turbines going all night long
offshore or in the Midwest.
But that's not where the demand is.
That's not where the load is.
So, you have to be able
to bring that somewhere.
And it's really good to have a,
you need storage and storage is coming.
It's here.
But the prices have to come down.
And just like in solar panel,
solar panels cost 10% of what they did
when I started over a decade ago.
They're 10% now.
And we're gonna get
the same thing with storage
and we're gonna get other system.
So I think,
Look, I'm MBA.
I'm not technical.
I wish I could develop
the next generation of solar panel
or a chemical reaction
that brings more energy better, faster.
That's not me.
That's a lot of smart people using AI
or other ways to invent the technologies
and improve the technologies.
I look at the world from a,
how do you get people to adapt?
What's the business model
that you can look at and says,
"I can get on one hand
the end user to adapt,
and on the other hand,
somebody to underwrite the risk
that technology will work
and that person will pay for it.
Why are there two billion people
without electricity
if we have solar, wind, water,
We have all these possibilities.
Why aren't we just spending
the billions necessary
and we are spending
the money on different things.
But why are we not spending them
on providing electricity?
What are we waiting for?
Is this policy issue,
a governmental bureaucracy issue?
Is this a technology issue?
I'd say it is 90%
government bureaucracy policy.
Not sending the grid into areas
that need the grid.
And if you go to these remote areas
that have democracy, for example,
you will often hear,
"Yes. The power grid is coming."
"Vote for me."
"I will get power to you."
"I will get electricity to you."
And every few years
when the election comes up,
the same types of promises are made.
But then there is not the follow through.
There's a technical challenge,
which is you have to run wires
and you have to build infrastructure.
And countries can do that.
And states or provinces can do that.
But it requires a level of discipline
and working through things.
And it's incredibly slow.
I mean, if you look at America,
we didn't have much electricity
a hundred years ago.
You know, we've got one of the
greatest grid in the world.
And that was done largely because
of policies and government support.
And I'm not saying that
we're in the same place
in these rural areas,
but there's so much more that can be done.
And I think business model evolution
is a part of what that is.
Right. It makes a lot of sensitivity.
After so many years in this industry,
what are you excited about today?
Tomorrow morning,
what are you gonna be working on
that really excites you.
New business models that basically take
policies, economics, incentives,
customer behavioral things.
We're working on some really
interesting things in New York City now
on community energy
and Ninedot Energy is leading the way.
And hopefully come September,
we will bring on
a seven and a half megawatt system,
which will bring 60 million
kilowatt hours a year
onto the grid for the next 25 years.
And our users will be
all over New York City.
And it's gonna support
the grid in unique ways.
So, I'm excited about.
And I'm also excited about more solar
and more electric vehicles,
Mopeds.
What is that?
What is a mopeds?
Electric mopeds like the rebel system,
which is just amazing.
Okay.
I love scooters and docking stations
like the one Swiftmile makes.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's just there's so much
cool stuff out there.
And in this covid area,
we kind of see a lot of problems
and life is gonna change.
And one of this things might change is
how we use our vehicles
and what types of vehicles we use
and which streets are like.
And how much of our land
we end up using to park cars
and to move cars.
You know, one of the most difficult things,
and I'm looking at Tel Aviv,
I'm riding here my bike in Palo Alto
and it's beautiful.
There's a bike lane everywhere.
It's so wide and wonderful.
I go to Tel Aviv Yafo and we have
hundreds of scooters waiting to be ridden.
And I'm scared to death.
I want to ride a scooter.
I want to ride my bike in Tel Aviv,
but I can't.
But I do wanna ask though,
we're both a part of J-Ventures.
And so, we're looking at a bunch
of early stage companies.
Are we seeing an increase in companies
that are dealing with these problems
or is there a shortage of good talent
that is trying to work with electricity,
with mobility,
within renewable energy?
There's a lot of talent coming in.
There's a lot of talent in the field.
The key thing and the signals
are going to be
how will investors
look at these opportunities?
And I think we have seen
a lot of excitement on vehicles, on rebel
which I mentioned the scooter craze.
What happened?
You know, it was a bubble
from a valuation side,
but it also prove the point.
And then created the opportunities
for things like these docking station
for a recharging economy.
So, there will be electric vehicle
and not just electric vehicles,
autonomous vehicles,
cars that we could think of,
truck lines that go on various routes
and then can draft behind each other
in very short separation
and save on fuel costs.
From that water,
and it's not just electricity.
It's also on the water side
and other resources that actually
consume a ton of electricity.
But there's opportunities.
Hopefully the venture crowd
and the venture world
and they have a lot of mind to think,
in the venture world
that they follow each other.
And when the word gets out
that clean tech is great,
Like it was in the [--],
then there is a lot of investment.
And then all of a sudden the word got out.
It's tough. We don't know enough.
So, I think that's gonna happen.
What I'm really excited about now is
kind of the combination of
very large commitments by companies
to lower their carbon footprint
and things that would have taken
four years to get through committees
and processes
to do a power purchase agreement
for a solar farm or whatever.
Now, whoever runs energy there
they could show that it's a fair deal,
a good deal, they're saving on carbon
and they're saving money.
They can get those through.
And that combined with the things like
the Gates Foundation
and our breakthrough energy
and other major foundations,
the Rockefeller family.
Folks who are saying,
"What got us here won't get us there."
And we're heading
from a climate side is disastrous.
We know this and,
but there's a lot of fund solutions out there.
And whether it's just high tech
and can develop something big,
or figure out a better model
for the scooters, how to move scooters,
how to build lanes for the scooters,
how to signal.
The one thing I'd love to throw out there
for the world that we need desperately
is a cheap, dispensable
or disposable helmet.
It comes with every scooter ride
and every little bike rental in the city.
That happens because people like you,
like me go on Tel Aviv,
we go on these scooters
and we are less of taxi
than we know we should be.
I completely agree.
David, I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Three words to describe myself.
Adventurous.
I love new adventures.
It's why I'm an entrepreneur.
And it's why I get to live
in different parts of the world.
This is a hyphenated word, Values driven.
Okay. Sure.
I do things that are consistent
with the values and work with people
who are consistent with the values
that I hold.
And Indomitable.
You may not know that word.
I don't.
I don't know the word in Hebrew,
But indomitable is
It's what entrepreneurs need to be.
They don't see at what age
as something that is insurmountable.
You keep going.
You keep working.
You try this way.
You try that way.
I love it.
And my friend Rich Kelly
gave me that name.
And I like indomitable.
So, there we go.
I love it.
David, thank you very much.
Toda raba.
Thank you for the inspiration.
Thank you for the work you're doing.
Toda raba Michael.This is a pleasure.
[--]
Toda raba. Bye bye.
Bye bye.